nous sommes ici dans l'abri sous l'autel
au sous sol pour nous protéger des
bombardements aériens les russes sont
entrés dans kiev et il ya des opérations
un peu au loin on entend des détonations
régulièrement je vais essayer de vous
montrer un petit peu ce qui se passe ici
vous pouvez voir il ya des enfants des
vieilles dames il y a des gens nous
sommes environ 50 ici beaucoup de
journalistes mais aussi des ukrainiens
qui sont venus se réfugier ici des gens
qui étaient dans le quartier ils les
témoignages rapportent que et bien les
forces russes sont entrés il y aurait
des chats au porte de kiev et des
combats de rue pas très loin d'ici
environ quatre stations de métro ça
c'est ce qu'on nous rapporte au sein des
forces de sécurité ukrainienne les
détonations ont retenti pendant la nuit
une grande détonation aux environs de 4
heures du matin puis à 6h30 environ à la
sirène a retenti pour nous intimer
l'ordre de descendre ici au sous sol
vous pouvez voir il y à de l'eau il ya
de la nourriture les gens sont descendus
avec leurs valises pour faire en sorte
de pouvoir partir aussi vite que
possible